we sometimes think that we're better
able to concentrate uh when we have a
lot of peace and quiet around us I find
the opposite I'm tomorrow I fly back to
Vancouver I'm in an airplane there's
lots of people and that's three hours
where I can concentrate on my iPhone or
my iPad studying my language when
there's a lot of distraction everywhere
else I'm better able to concentrate if I
sit down in a quiet room in a library
and put my earphones in and I'm gonna
just listen all of a sudden my mind
starts to wander whereas when there's
lots of distraction and maybe that's why
people go to a coffee shop because work
or study or read Because if you can shut
off the distraction somehow you're
better able to focus so things are not
always what they see anyway tomorrow I
fly back to Vancouver and I'll be
learning languages polish right now bye
for now